sur la turquie lesieu ce qui est menaces
qui continuent à narguer les européens
en méditerranée avec l'envoi de navires
d'exploration
vous avez l'impression aussi qu'on
arrive à se mettre d'accord et que des
sanctions soient en quelque sorte
inéluctable parce que les négociations
se font pas de bonne foi
écoutez là aussi je pense qu il y à un
consensus émergent ans au sein du
conseil européenne que la turquie
représente un problème menace systémique
ce n'est pas que la question de
l'instabilité de 2 à la méditerranée
orientale
ici il ya un comportement systémique qui
commence à libye qui continue en syrie
au cours distant maintenant nagorno
karabagh à la méditerranée orientale
les amis turcs doivent décider avec qui
ils veulent être dans ce monde
s'ils veulent être avec nous ou proche
de nous en tant que membre de l'otan un
pays candidat à l'adhésion
ça a un coût il faut un certain
comportement
si par contre il préfère l'iran at-elle
annua match là c'est un autre choix et
je pense que tôt ou tard nous a mis tous
que devront faire ses choix stratégiques
et l'europe agira en fonction de cette
décision